You're noticeably different than the
everyday Muslim. What does hukan mean?
What does hukan mean? Means criterion.
Okay. So what does it mean? A standard
of truth that tells you what's right and
WHAT'S [laughter]
THE QURAN SAYS THE TORAH IS ALPHA.
According to your Quran, the Torah is
alpha. In chapter 21:48 and in chapter
2:53, the Torah is alone. [laughter]
>> [laughter]
>> I need to get dressed for the occasion.
I'm getting My shirt's getting messy.
Hold on. What's this guy doing? You want
You want to throw the towel? You want to
throw the towel, boy? You want to throw
the towel? I just I just need to dress.
>> Yeah, this is for the occasion.
>> I need to dress for the occasion, man.
>> Okay, here's a here's a question, too.
I've ever made
>> What do you mean? You're the only one
acting religion. Is the father god? I
already answered this. Can you tell us
what life's law is? Are are you I need
to repeat myself the fourth time. You
don't even know who Len get your
thoughts together. What is Lieben's law?
>> I've already explained to you. It's the
law of identity.
>> No, that's a it's a category within the
>> Specifically law. It's it's the law of
identity. It's the same as the law of
identity. That's they call it lenet law.
>> Len's law is that something is identical
if and only if they are identical. They
share all the properties. They are
identical. All of their properties. Is
that correct?
>> Yeah, he's you're reading the over AI
overview, right?
>> I'm looking at you.
>> My friend telling me that law.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> I had to teach you on what Liven's law
was. Thank you.
>> He's a stupid guy.
>> I don't father god. It's a father god
from a lit philosophers also reject law
of identity.
>> Father God from a linen law identity.
>> From a law identity. I don't hold to
that. I don't hold law.
>> Ah. So you have to reject it. Do you?
>> Yes. I don't hold to his law. Oh, so you
have to reject liveness lord. You do you
have to you don't know where to go. Hold
on. Hold on. Do you accept What are you
laughing at? What are you laughing at?
What are you laughing at?
>> I'm I'm laughing because you don't know
where to go from here. Your script was
destroyed. I don't have to your view
of Lieben's law in order to hold to the
law of identity. The law of identity
works with relative identity. I'm not
rejecting the law of identity.
So you can be identical in one sense
while having distinctions in another.
It's simple. So here's an example. The
Titanic before it got shipped off. It's
in perfect condition. No scratches, no
bangs. It's shipped off, crashes into
the glacier, sinks. Is the Titanic that
left the shore absolutely identical in
every way to the Titanic that crashed
into the glacier and is sunk. Sunken.
What? What? So why
>> is the Titanic that left the the shore
the same as the one that sunk?
>> They absolutely identical in every way.
>> PROBABLY NOT BECAUSE IT'S
>> OH, BUT IT'S STILL the Titanic. You just
affirmed identity disregarding absolute
identity. That's why you're confused.
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit are
identical in essence while being
distinct in personhood or hypoasis. The
Quran says that mu which means it's a
guardian and it is a filter for the
truth.
>> Oh, now it's a guardian. I thought it
was
mu means the corrector. It's the one
that corrects it. Well, mu and ali. How
do you explain that please? How do you
>> before you do the Muslim shuffle the
hijab twostep? So, it depends on your
interpretation because you have some
interpreters that interpreted that
Muhammad
who was a Muhammad over the Quran. And
so then if you're going to be consistent
then you're gonna have to say Muhammad
is an authority or corrector over the
words of Allah.
>> No no no
the the Quran is al it's called al
Muhammad. Would you like to see
otherwise that say Muhammad the Muhamm
the verse is very clear that the Quran
is the Muhammad.
>> Not to everybody to some of your
scholars they said Muhammad is the Mahu.
You see, look, you're having to lie now.
This is quite
>> Do you want me to show you? Can I share
my screen? No. No. You don't need to
share [laughter]
waste. Don't waste the the scholars of
Islam, people like
to
>> they have made it very clear that they
believe that what's in with the
Christians and the Jews today is
corrupt. which scholars like I said in
Kalani mentions that we and our friends
he says this that what's in the hands of
the the the Christians
is
it is distorted textually
>> that's what I can you show us the
reference
>> yeah it's in I can pull it up I can't
right now I'm drinking my tea I'm
sitting down you can find it you think
I'd lie to you about that or lying cuz
you li you've been lying this whole time
this is uncontroversial
let me show you why it's controversial
says I I know there are some scholars
who didn't believe that. I
>> Yeah, I know that.
>> I'm loving your honesty. So there's some
scholars who believe in corruption and
there's some scholars who find wholesale
preservation. That's beautiful. Good
job. Good job. I mean, they don't
believe in Oh, let me tell you this. So
Ibent Tamia believed in the following.
He didn't believe in wholesome
preservation. Okay. So we we treat the
Bible like we treat weak as well and
that's considered to be a strong
version.
>> What does Bkari's like?
>> Okay. He huh?
>> What does Bkari say? Abkari there's a
difference of opinion about him who
obviously is interpreting alkari says
that al bkari has this view which
indicates that they may have had some
kind of preserved text at the time okay
he indicates
>> may have he doesn't say may have he says
they definitely have says that I don't
think he says that I don't he's unsure
about it but what I'm saying to you is
that you can interpret bkari maybe like
that yeah you can
>> but what I'm saying to you is
>> huh bkari that's what he says some
>> scholars Islam might have believed in
this. I'm not negating this point that
the Jews and Christians at the time of
the prophet had some kind of preserved
text.
>> So then this means that our position is
is completely Islamic that the
scriptures are uncorrupted.
>> Some scholars of Islam, some scholars,
classical scholars of Islam might have
believed that. As I said to you, the
point I'm making to you is this. It's
very clear that the scholars, the
overwhelming vast majority of Muslim
scholars believed that what's in the
hands of the Christians and the Jews is
corrupt. What is your evidence that the
majority of the early scholars of Islam
believe that the previous scriptures
were textually correct?
>> My evidence is what Kalani mentions in
where he said that our Bkari said
something else. The overwhelming vast
majority of Muslim scholars from the
classical period until now believe that
this Bible that we have in our hands is
>> Show me that corrupt.
>> Show me that. Don't just say that. I
don't reference of that. Show me that
the reference.
>> Show us brother. You You can't be making
big. What you going to show? What do
>> you mean? You got all those books behind
you. You don't got a a reference. You
don't got the source that you can show
us with me in this house. This is quite
pathetic. He goes on to say it's altered
and corrupted from a textual
perspective. We want to see that because
according to other scholars as you
already agreed they don't hold that
position where they believe in wholesale
preservation of the scriptures and they
quote verses the same verses that we use
today that none can alter the words of
Allah. They they even use the hadith
that a lot of Muslims today try to say
is is not authentic Abu Davu 449 where
Muhammad puts the Torah in the judgment
seat. They use these arguments to
substantiate. So right side that says
>> you're right on that point.
>> I know I'm right on that. Thank you for
telling me. I appreciate it.
>> The point is this. The prophet wasallam
mentioned Yeah. in aith
do not bely them and do not believe
them. The people of the past you know
this hadith.
>> Yes. So what is what does he say?
>> So so so hold on. There are aspects of
no aspects of this.
>> Finish the last line. You're skipping a
line.
>> That's that's the hadith.
>> Okay. Let me let me teach you. He says,
"Do not
do not deny them and do not believe."
>> I got you. He says, "Do not believe them
nor disbelieve them, but say we have we
believe in what was revealed to us and
what is revealed to you."
>> Sure. You just read it. The point I'm
making, am I correct? Says, "Do not
believe them. Do not bel them." So the
issue is this.
>> So what are they supposed to say?
>> Yeah. Yeah. And tell them that we've
believed in what was revealed to Abraham
and Jacob and Isaac, etc. In the Quran,
it's mentioned. So he you're supposed to
believe in what they have and what you
have. Looking on your own hadith. What
are you talking about, man? Are you
talking about
the Quran says that the hadith says that
don't bely them and don't believe them.
Which means that there's something in
circulation. There is something in
circulation from which is you may remain
agnostic about.
>> No.
>> If the Quran contradicts it, then the
Quran takes precedence. Never said that.
Muhammad never correcting you as me a
question. Let me answer. You asked me a
question.
>> Is the Quran correcting the question?
Let me answer. The answer is the answer
is no. And Muhammad never ever says that
the Quran is correcting the previous
scripture. Let me ask you the question.
Let me ask you the question. You trying
to jump out the rest. When the Quran
says, stop trying to jump like the rest,
man. Stay in there. The Quran says that
no weariness touched God. Is that a
correction of the Genesis and Exodus
narrative or not? Yes or no? I'm going
to correcting what's in the hands of the
Bible or not. Is it correct or not?
>> I'm going to answer you in full. The
answer is no. It is not a correction.
And no, it is not a correction. The
Bible doesn't even teach.
Notice how you're even teached
God. In fact, it talks about him ceasing
working on the seventh day. Not that he
was actually tired and allowing me to
answer in you must be scared boy. You
must be scared boy. The hadith that you
are referring to where it says don't
believe what they say nor disbelieve
what they say but this is what you
respond to this why you chang believe.
Let me finish.
>> Why are you changing the subject? No,
you're the one who changed the subject.
You brought this up.
>> The prophet sallallaihi wasallam
mentioned in a hadith do not bel them
and do not believe them. Do you know
this hadith ink say believe
us
what was revealed to you? Okay. So what
I'm trying to say is that in the book of
Genesis it's mentioned yeah that God
rested. However in the book of Exodus
chapter number 31 verse number 17. Okay.
In that verse the word is that he not
only rested but he refreshed. And the
Hebrew word is nafash. So here clearly
in the Old Testament corpus you have
this idea of God actually literally
resting. If you find if you look at all
of the the the the the rabbitical
commentary about that it's an actual
rest. So the point is this you're saying
when the Quran says
in chapter number 50 in that it's not
correcting this. So what is it
correcting then? No it is not
correction. Muhammad is ignorant of what
is in the previous scriptures and he's
only going by word of mouth. Here's an
example. The example is what you brought
up in the hadith that you had no idea
about. The hadith says that you're
referring to, it says that the Jews used
to recite the Torah in Hebrew and then
explain it in Arabic. So according to
the hadith that you brought up, it
destroys you because it shows that
they're hearing by word of mouth.
They're having the Torah explained to
them in Arabic by some of the Jews. Then
in response, Muhammad says, "Don't
believe what they say, nor disbelieve
what they say, but in response say, we
believe in what was revealed to us and
what was revealed to you." So they can't
trust the Jews on if they're lying or
not of what their scriptures say, cuz
they don't know it. They don't know the
scriptures themselves. They're only
going by word of mouth. So Muhammad is
not correcting nothing. And he's
ignorant of squiggles.